le jaune doit être probablement la
couleur la plus présente dans la tête
d'un archer toucher ce fameux centre de
la cible doit provoquer de nombreux
moments de doute dans une carrière
membre de l'équipe de France au début
des années 2000 l'expérience de Sandrine
Varley lui permet d'appréhender le pas
de tir plus sereinement dans un sport où
l'aspect mental est primordial faut
rester bien concentré c'est vrai que ça
dure à peu près 3 He la compétition faut
savoir rester concentré au bon moment et
être régulier dans sa concentration et
dans son tien sin stress monte plus avec
les lors des matchs quoi lors des duels
éliminatoires la tension de l'arc peut
créer quelques tremblements il faut donc
avoir une confiance en soi inébranlable
pour tirer la flèche au bon moment sans
être obsédé par le mille la mécanique
doit être parfaitement huilée de façon à
ce que le lâcher de flèche devienne
quasiment artistique si on pense au
centre de la cible on le fait pas voilà
il faut absolument être disons avoir une
technique qui estune technique une bonne
technique de façon à pouvoir lâcher sa
flèche correctement j'oriente mon arc
vers la cible et une fois que c'est en
cible je n'y pense plus je je cherche à
tracctter uniquement la flèche mais si
on pense au jaune c'est sûr on fait pas
jaune 260 archers étaient présents sur
le pas de tir ce weekend les archers de
Guill en course se sont illustrés avec
une médaille d'or en vétéran le club
cquentinois organisera le championnat
régional en salle en février
prochain